All righty then, it is time for "Drew's News."
Your hand-picked bushel of juicy good news berries.
Yum.
With me at the desk is my little boysenberry,
Rossi Ross Matthews.
Hi.
(audience applauding)
Pluck me.
Hi, everybody.
Oh, yellow, Drew.
Well, I'm excited for our first story, Rossi,
because someone is sort of preaching something
that I definitely feel like I've said.
And people get all, you know, higgeldy-piggeldy about it,
so, I'm kind of excited.
I feel like I have a sister out in the universe.
I know, and I'm not a big fan of this.
You know that, well, we disagree.
We'll see what the people think.
That's true, all right, for anyone who loved
"The Flight Attendant"
did anyone love "The Flight Attendant"?
(applause)
Love Kaley.
Well, it's back on HBO Max, and Kaley Cuoco is back
for more nail-biting drama, but when it comes to marriage,
this flight attendant is cooling her jets.
People reports, Kaley just divorced from Karl Cook,
her second husband, and she says quote,
"I will never get married again."
She said she'd love a long-term partner
but marriage is absolutely not happening.
And she said that people could quote her
and put that right on the cover.
Yeah, well, yes, and good for her
if that's what she wants.
I don't like it, and I'll tell you why.
Have you ever been in a position where you ate a whole pizza
to yourself, and you're like, "Oh my God, I'm never eating
pizza again."
(crowd chuckles)
And then, you know, a day comes around when you're like,
"You know what sounds good?
Is some pizza."
And I'm just telling you, you may be saying now, Drew,
"I never wanna get married again."
But what about one day, 30 years from now,
you meet somebody who's your person
and it's important to them, right?
Do you think maybe then you'd change your mind?
Nope.
No?
Nope, absolutely not.
What if they fed you pizza?
If we brought it wrapped around to that, would you?
If you wrapped anything up in pizza,
I feel like I'd be in.
I just, I think what she's trying to say is like,
it's not that you're not a romantic anymore,
or that you judge other people or you don't wanna be
at their weddings or everybody could get married around you.
It's like, almost like you realize, you're not good
at this thing and you don't wanna try it anymore.
You know, I can respect that, I can.
I just want there to be a little crack in the window
where you're like, can change your mind.
Is that too much to ask, that you could change your mind?
Some people rock it, like Elizabeth Taylor, and you know,
JLo and Ben.
People have marriages, they get back together or, you know,
they do it and they just make it look so cool.
Yeah.
I don't feel like I'm like that guy.
Okay.
(crowd chuckles)
I feel like it's like, oh God.
If you break up, you break up,
it's not the world's biggest deal,
but a divorce just feels like such a, ugh, it's,
I don't know, I don't think I can take it again.
I get that, and I have your back, and I just wanna say,
in 30 years, if you text me, "Oh my God, Ross,
I'm getting married."
I won't say, "I told you so" Okay?
(crowd laughs)
(applause)
I won't.
I won't even bring it up.
I won't show you this clip.
I won't say a word.
You know, I hope that one day I eat my own words
and you play this clip and you rub my nose in it.
I do, I hope that I'm wrong.
Oh, did you hear that?
She said, "I do" Did you hear that?
She said it.
(Drew laughs)
(applause)
(Ross laughs)
Ah, you're just practicing.
Maybe I am, and maybe I am.
Stay tuned, everybody, stay tuned.
See, that took a turn.
All right, well there's an exciting Halloween movie brewing,
and it might be a new instant classic.
Jezebel reports filming just wrapped on a movie called,
"Spirit Halloween."
It's a spooky movie set inside one of those
Spirit Halloween stores.
You know, they just pop up, so you're like,
"when'd that get here?"
Well, now it stars the incredible Christopher Lloyd,
who we love.
Oh man, Christopher Lloyd, Back to the Future, Taxi.
The best.
He's in it, and you can see, and he's so great
at playing creepy, plus there's a cast of young
middle schoolers who dare each other to spend a night
locked inside a Spirit Halloween, and they're saying
it's inspired by classics like The Goonies and Gremlins.
And those Spirit Halloween stores, I mean, they're so great,
except I always end up going in on like, October 30th
at 8:00 PM, and there's nothing scarier than that scene
in a Spirit Halloween, and it's in a weird, old,
empty Sears they just turned into a Spirit Halloween store.
You wanna watch this, and would you spend a night in one?
I mean, there's no doubt I'm gonna be seeing this movie
'cause this is my daughter Frankie's fantasy come to life.
You saw her birthday invitation.
Oh yeah, yeah, yeah.
It's like a ghost and she was like, "I want a bloody,
death-themed birthday party."
And I was like, "Okay, I don't know how to phrase that
on a invitation that is not gonna get me outed
in the parent community."
So she's gonna be all over this.
Yeah?
Yeah.
You wanna go see this movie when it comes out, together?
Can I bring Frankie?
Of course!
Yes, then done.
I'll be scared, Frankie can comfort me.
Yeah, exactly.
She's not scared by anything.
(upbeat music)